at this altitude I can run my hands this
episode is brought to you by brave the
next generation web browser
I love brave and if you haven't heard
about it here is the skinny brave was
built by team of privacy focused
performance oriented pioneers of the web
and I do mean pioneers brave was
co-founded by Brendan Eich the I CH in
Brian Bondi Brendan was previously the
co-founder of Mozilla Firefox and the
creator of JavaScript brave now has more
than 10 million monthly active users and
I'm one of them why why would I use
brave because brave gives you unmatched
speed security and privacy and when I
say unmatched I mean the difference is
hard to believe and here's why every
time you download a web page when you go
to any web page you are not just
downloading the text and images you are
also downloading web junk this includes
trackers and scripts that run in the
background slowing your downloads and
wasting your time by an average of 5
seconds per page while also draining
your battery faster and costing you
extra in data charges there is a way to
have the best experience web can offer
and that is by using brave brave is up
to 6 times faster than other browsers
and it's truly incredible how much
faster everything is I have used brave
for instance to get on airplane Wi-Fi
when other browsers crash I have used it
to watch YouTube videos when it's just
suspended in loading forever on other
browsers it's not subtle at all there's
a huge difference other browsers act
like a vacuum cleaner for your data so
this is on the security privacy side you
were being profiled and tracked across
the web so what you might ask well data
collected about you can be used to
manipulate both your decisions and
countrywide decisions like elections and
if you want more on that listen to my
episode with Tristan Harris brave is a
way to protect yourself and remove the
surveillance economy brave also include
options which I use quite often such as
private window with tour for those
seeking advanced privacy and safety this
browser feels intuitive it's super easy
to use you can import your bookmarks
with one-click and all your favorite
Chrome extensions are also available
with brave and it doesn't have to be
either/or you can use multiple browsers
for different things now
listeners of this show the Tim fair show
can easily upgrade their browser for
free and all you have to do is go to
brave comm forward slash Tim that's
brave com forward slash Tim I use brave
all the time and I strongly suggest that
you at least test it out so go to brave
comm forward slash Tim and give it a
shot this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs it's a new year 2020 time
for clarity a time when lots of folks
are thinking about personal and
professional growth and in many cases
the growth of their own businesses big
goals necessitating good planning and
good hires if that's you LinkedIn can
help you find the right people who can
set you up for a strong year LinkedIn
jobs screens candidates with the hard
and soft skills you're looking for so
you can hire the right person quickly
how is it that a person is hired every
eight seconds with LinkedIn and why is
it that companies have rated LinkedIn
jobs the number one platform for
delivering quality hires collaboration
creativity adaptability LinkedIn simply
has more and better data they can look
beyond pure work skills and put your job
post in front of qualified candidates
who match your business requirements
perfectly that's how LinkedIn makes sure
that your job post is seen by the people
you want to hire people with the skills
qualifications and interests that will
help you and your business grow so find
the right person for your business today
with LinkedIn jobs you can pay what you
want and get the first $50 off
just visit linkedin.com slash tim again
that's linkedin.com slash Tim to get $50
off of your first job post terms and
conditions apply
well hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show or it is my job
to deconstruct world-class performers
people who are exceptionally good at
whatever they do whether that is in the
realm of business the world of finance
or the military or art or magic or truth
saying or skepticism and we check a
bunch of boxes for my guest today who is
Penn Jillette Penn Jillette I've wanted
to have Penn on this podcast for many
years now Penn Jillette Jil le TT E is a
cultural phenomenon as a solo
personality and as half of the world
famous Emmy award-winning magic duo and
Las Vegas headliners Penn & Teller I've
been watching and enjoying Penn & Teller
for most of my life together since 1975
Penn & Teller's live show spent years on
Broadway and is now the longest-running
headliner show in Las Vegas where it
plays nightly at the Rio all Suite Hotel
and Casino the pair has been awarded Las
Vegas magicians of the year and amazing
eight times as part of Penn & Teller he
has appeared on hundreds of shows we
could spend five minutes listing them
but I'll mention just a few from the
Simpsons to friends and billions he
recently co-wrote an episode of the
emmy-winning Netflix series black
mirrors while one of my favorite series
he co-hosted the controversial Showtime
series Penn & Teller [ __ ]
exclamation point which was nominated
for 13 Emmy Awards won him a Writers
Guild Award and was the longest-running
show in the history of the network he
currently hosts the CW network hit
competition series Penn & Teller fool us
which was nominated for a 2017 Critics
Choice Award Penn's latest book the New
York Times best seller presto takes an
insightful and very humorous look at his
recent weight loss journey which we dig
into in great depth in our conversation
he lost more than a hundred pounds in
record time and his previous book God no
signs you might be an atheist and
another magic tales spent six weeks on
the New York Times best sellers list his
weekly podcast which I recommend
checking out it's a lot of fun Penn's
Sunday school was
the number one downloaded podcast on
Apple podcast during its debut week and
was named best new comedy podcast by
Apple podcasts on the big screen
this guy's everywhere he does everything
pen produced the critically lauded 2005
documentary the aristocrats which
features more than 100 of the biggest
names in comedy telling their versions
of the dirtiest joke in history he then
produced Tim's Vermeer which is one of
my favorite documentaries and we spent
some time on this which follows the
journey of an eccentric inventor
determined to solve one of the art
world's oldest mysteries and if Tim
that's the eccentric inventor who
happens to be based I believe here in
Texas is listening please let me know
would love to have you on the show the
Sony Pictures classic release of Tim's
Vermeer was nominated for a BAFTA and
was shortlisted for the 2014 Oscars he
most recently completed the documentary
the gamblers Ballad profiling magic
legend Johnny Thompson Penn & Teller
have their very own star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame and triumphantly
returned to Broadway recently with Penn
& Teller on Broadway which was the
highest-grossing non-musical for the
entirety of its run you can find Penn on
Twitter if you want to say hello at Penn
Jillette PE nnj il L et te you can find
Penn's Sunday school at Penn Sunday
school comm and you can find links to
all of these things and everything we
talked about at tim dot blog /n p en n
so all of that said without further ado
please enjoy this very wide-ranging
conversation with none other than hen
Jillette
pen welcome to the show very nice to be
here we have a lot of mutual friends
would be pleasant to finally kind of
sort of meet you ish that's right I feel
like we've been sort of circling like
electrons never quite intersecting with
this Venn diagram with a lot of overlap
and I want to give a thank you to Brian
Koppelman for making the intro at Brian
for those who don't know is one of my
more compulsively productive friends
co-creator of the hit show billions also
part of the writing pair the dynamic duo
behind The Illusionist rounders many
many other films how did you get to know
Brian geez I don't know that's somehow
lost the fog of time I know that he had
seen our show and really really liked it
and I don't know exactly how our paths
crossed it's funny because I considered
him a friend and we spent quite a bit of
time together but I don't really know
how it started I'm sure somebody does
maybe he does maybe his wife does or
maybe that information is lost for all
time and I don't think Humanity is much
worse for why are the two of you friends
what what what are the bonds interests
eccentricities anything that have helped
you guys to be friends I can imagine
what they might be or some of them but
but why what attitude you guys have
become friends many many of those many
of those questions are answered with one
word and that is Dylan an interest in in
in in Bob Dylan and that kind of writing
have brought me to everybody from you
know Salman Rushdie and Christopher
Hitchens to Brian Koppelman we talk a
lot about Dylan I think we oh I know I
do know where we met it was some sort of
party for one of those ocean numbers
ocean's eleven twelve thirty one of them
right here in here in Vegas and we were
up at some big
fancy party and eh I didn't want to be
at and he came over and started chatting
with me we started arguing rather
aggressively about religion and I'm
happy to say that I he came around to
much closer to my point of view over the
years but we talked about Dylan and we
talked about God those two ideas almost
interchangeable to any thinking versus
if there is a Bob Dylan I think we'll
definitely circle back to that I want to
bring up someone who's become really of
great interest to me only in the last
few years which is somewhat embarrassing
to admit and it came visa vie a
documentary called an honest liar and
that's James Randi for people who don't
know who James Randi is could you
describe who he is but also how you came
to be influenced by James Randi
well Randy is is is is so much to me
that it's that's almost hard to give a a
capsule bio I mean personally Randi is
maybe the most important person outside
of my family in my entire life I just
was with him a couple days ago for about
an hour which is about all he's really
has the energy for now but I was
mentalism fake mind reading I changed my
life rather profoundly I a hack horrible
medalist named Kreskin was on some TV
talk show when I was a child when I was
about 12 and it couldn't have been
Johnny Carson because Johnny Carson
didn't allow him on and once again I
don't trust my memory I I keep an
elaborate journal so I
is one way to teach yourself that you
don't remember things properly but he
had done a magic trick on a television
show that he passed off his science he
passed off as ESP this is Kreskin and
I'm not from a wealthy family my father
was a jail guard but I was very very
good in the sciences and very good in
school and so they bought me this ESP
kit to study the science that I'd seen
on television and I spent a lot of time
by parents running these ESP experiments
and doing all of this and then because I
was juggling at the time I I would go to
the library and is everybody who's
familiar with the Dewey Decimal System
knows magic and juggling are very close
together under the Arts nobody cares
about right there with realism
and mine and arts that aren't really art
and I happened upon a book by Don injure
was a medalist in the 30s and 40s I
guess and there in it was a trick very
similar to the one that Kreskin had done
and I realized that I had been scammed
and I was appalled that a scientist
would lie to children and my grades went
from straight A's to flunking in
everything I hated science I hated magic
I was very very alienated I went to rock
and roll and it wasn't until I was 18
and mint teller and Randi within a short
period of time that I realized that it
was it was possible to be moral and be a
scientist and be moral and be a magician
the latter being harder of course and
teller and I started a conversation
about how magic could be intellectual
and magic could be polite and magic
could be respectful to magic to be moral
all things that it wasn't in my
experience
and then Randy wrote a book flim-flam
that I read before that I think once
again I'm enough of a skeptic and I'm
aware enough of the science around this
but I do know that what I'm telling you
here is emotionally correct but probably
not actually accurate because that long
ago and that emotional you conflate
things and then every time you tell the
story you change it so I'm aware of that
I'm aware that I don't know so I want to
make clear to you that I'm telling you a
a poetic and emotional truth and Randy
was so open and so giving and showed me
I mean my entire career path I mean I
could not have done magic if not for
Randy I could not have been a kind
skeptic without Randy I would not have
the balls I have without Randy and he
became a guiding light from when I met
him when I was 18 you know 73 until you
know this second I have not given a bio
of Randy I've talked about myself
personally James Randi was a magician an
escape artist a Mentalist and then
realized that he was hurting people with
his lies his claims of mind-reading and
he became a crusader to let people know
that parapsychology and the paranormal
were as far as we've discovered so far
non-existent he he's one of the few
people that has changed their career
path that much I mean the other one of
course was Houdini and the other one who
will come back to over and over again is
Bob Dylan but he was able to change his
career from magician to skeptic
and Randy is also an autodidact he did
not go to college which is something
else I shared with him and therefore was
not taken seriously at first by
scientists and has since then made it
very clear that when scientists are
testing people who claim powers they
kinda need a magician on their team
because scientists are not used to being
lied to
there's an awful lot of study of
scientists being aware that they lie to
themselves I mean n waves and all of
this other stuff that's come up and
there's a lot of things put in place in
the scientific method to guard against
that but there isn't a lot in the
scientific method to guard against
people lying to you I mean test tubes
don't change themselves from one place
to another overnight you know radio
telescopes don't give false information
that you know that is malicious and
Randy has been there and I think he's
done huge amounts for science in letting
people know that that people who claim
psychic powers probably don't have them
and one scene or segment of an honest
liar which I highly recommend to people
it's also very meta I mean I want to
give away some of the biography of his
that makes it such an interesting twist
in the movie but he demonstrates how at
times conscious but often times
subconscious self-deception can be in
the sense that or confirmation bias I
recall this segment in the film where he
trains two young men who later go on to
perform as mentalists and so on to
deceive researchers who are studying
phenomena under the umbrella of
parapsychology or ESP and he then gives
a list effectively a checklist to the
researchers to defend against the types
of deceit that could throw their studies
or results sideways and
and they do not follow them hit and it's
really a fascinating study of human
nature in a way and I'm curious how you
would suggest to people if there are any
approaches tools heuristics whatever
comes to mind of that people can use to
become less gullible or more skeptical
and less susceptible to deceit well
first thing one needs to do is to work
very hard to be skeptical without being
cynical of the of the seven billion
people on the planet if we round it off
about seven billion or good I do not
believe in God I also do not believe in
the existence of evil I believe there's
very little bad in the world there's a
lot of mistakes but not people
maliciously trying to do bad things so
your chances of coming across someone
who is actually scamming you are fairly
low my rule of thumb is if you pick
someone you're really safe if they pick
you you have to be careful if I Drive in
front of a Starbucks with my brand-new
Tesla and I run into the Starbucks and I
say listen my but my wife is is is is is
about to give birth we have to go to the
hospital she's in an uber here's the
keys to my Tesla here's my phone number
please can you park it somewhere and
then give me a call later and tell me
where thank you and I run out and I just
throw those keys in the air and someone
grabs them my Tesla's really safe really
really safe if someone comes up to me
and says can I help you I have to be
very very wary that's because they have
selected themselves
you want to if random selects or you
select you're doing okay if someone
selects you you have to be a little a
little cautious so if somebody comes to
you and says I you know if you go to
somebody and say I want to talk to you
about my problems I want to be friends
with you I want to pour my heart out
your chances are pretty good of whoever
you talk to is gonna be okay if someone
comes to you and says I can help you
with your problems your your spidey
sense your tingle I mean that is a very
different way of looking at it than I've
heard other people say but I think is
fairly useful
that being said all the stuff that that
you know the the generation before mine
was kind of taught like don't try to get
something for nothing which is also
known as the you know second law of
thermodynamics don't try to get
something for nothing if something seems
too good to be true it is and
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence I don't need a
lot of evidence that the Starbucks
around the corner is going to still be
there tomorrow I need a lot of evidence
for perpetual motion and that those
kinds of things work pretty well the
other thing is if you if you desperately
want to believe something if something
feels you with joy sadly you have to be
a little careful of that I mean I
remember when there were all sorts of
stories about l ron hubbard having
pitched his exact scientology is a
science fiction novel you know the year
before and you hear that story is a
skeptic and you go boom bang boom
and you gotta be very careful of those
things you know people that I know who
are who are very very anti-trump and
very distressed about that we're
thrilled to pieces that he hired
prostitutes to piss all over they love
that story and immediately all their
skepticism went away as to where that
came from and also the fact that Trump
is not hip enough to do anything
slightly kinky I mean I would I would
dig him so much more if that story
happens but then again it's very hard
for me to imagine digging them less but
those are kind of my rules I I haven't
given them you know with with the kind
of bullet points and clickbait one would
like to see them but those those are
honestly the kinds of things I think
about what I'm when I'm assessing
whether something is real or not
thank you you mentioned journaling
earlier and I know that Brian for
instance compliment who came up earlier
does a lot of journaling and he has a
very specific approach to journaling he
tends to use a format called morning
pages which was popularized by Julia
Cameron sort of what he might call her
what she might call spiritual windshield
wipers which sort of capturing stream of
consciousness but then you have all
manner of different types of journaling
Reed Hoffman a feeling LinkedIn or Josh
Waitzkin the person associated with
searching for Bobby Fischer they all
have different approaches how do you
journal how do you use journaling well
you know it was very funny when I was 30
years old I regretted deeply not keeping
a journal and I can't read my own
writing and my typing is very very fast
but I'm very bothered by any sort of
mistake at all and then I go back and
retype it and it's terrible my mom was a
typing teacher and Tommy too
so I've been typing since I was 12
so there was no way that worked for me
for me to record things before computers
when I was 30 years old we became a very
successful off-broadway and Teller and I
had a very strong rule that we did not
celebrate successes because we'd seen
friends you know get a record contract
and then buy a car and that seemed
incredibly stupid so teller and I had
big things happen we would you know
celebrate with coffee and donuts and
that was the end you know but I had
promised myself that if we got a good
review of the New York Times which in
1985 meant something it doesn't now but
it did mean something that that and that
are Ron off-broadway was going to
continue that I would buy myself a
computer and in a bass guitar and a good
bass guitar and that happened when I
bought myself a my first computer and
when I first sat down not the computer
the very first things I wrote were
published his short stories I mean I
went from not writing to writing
constantly and then it's very funny to
think of this but at 30 years old I
thought man I haven't kept the journal
there was all this street performing and
when I was homeless and living on the
streets and all of that that I haven't
recorded nothing's gonna happen from
here on but I guess just for the hell of
it I'll start keeping a journal you know
and that was you know uh 34 years ago
and I guess it's not literally true that
I haven't missed a day there may have
been a day that was I was unconscious
but he's certainly fewer than five days
I've missed in 34 days and I do not have
a any sort of particular system I write
the date the time where I am and then I
usually write I got up I then record the
previous 24 hours I take notes on every
conversation I've had I I write a book
report and every book I've read I write
a movie report every movie I've watched
I write an art report and every Museum
or artistic thing I've experienced and
as I said notes and every conversation I
don't know how much it is probably five
hundred to a thousand words a day
I should not much it is and then and I
believe this is the part that may be the
most useful obviously not when I started
but since then every morning I read 20
years ago ten years ago and one year ago
now those numbers for how long ago have
of course changed you know used to be
five but I find that maybe the more
useful the most useful part of my
journaling because I time travel so
every morning it's mostly morning I to
myself 20 years ago I talked to myself
10 years ago and I talked to myself last
year and I read that entry and I will
tell you back when I was dating if you
were a a sexual partner of mine and you
happen to have the exact same argument
one year ago that you had that day I can
tell you right now it was over because
if I look back and see the same problem
2010 or one year ago
attention must be paid I like to see
different problems so that is pretty
much by journaling and I usually also do
something I found that's kind of nice
and that I will pull parts out of my
journal and send them to the people that
important I mean my friend lawrence
O'Donnell has a show on MSNBC one of my
closest friends he insists that I am the
only record that he's been on this
planet because I sent him my
conversation with him from 20 years ago
ten years ago in last year and I said
the medieval and he says you know there
is no evidence whatsoever that this
happened except your journal I remember
nothing of it but I do that and also
just recently which is I think this is a
crazy thing just this month I started
adding pictures and I don't know why it
was just this month but I just I just
started to and I don't know how that's
gonna feel but it seems good and then
what I did my 14 day fast I also did a
video journal every day because I was
interested in how I would look and I
would feel how my voice would sound but
that's my journaling and since I started
doing that which I did not follow
anyone's pattern on that you know I was
just trying to be a you know 16 year old
girl with a diary you know that's all I
was trying to do but since then I found
that there are many psychologists and
therapists they use that reading the
past thing as a as a way of focusing
one's thoughts but I didn't know about
it when I started and I wasn't following
anybody's rules on that and would you
say that the are the main benefits that
you feel I mean it is a habit that
you've developed over time so you may
just have the momentum of that habit but
are can you discern the benefits that
you get from doing this on a daily basis
is it a is it a matter of purging things
so that you feel that they're safely
captured somewhere is it the benefit
that you get from the revisiting
yourself with these various snapshots
that
what do you get from putting the time
that you do into journaling it's hard to
say it's a small amount of time I mean
the whole process with reading the past
and writing is probably 20 to 30 minutes
I am very ritualistic very habitual and
we you know everybody that thinks about
habits which I believe is everybody
knows that the upside the downside of
being a vigilar are pretty
well-documented but it's very hard for
me to get out of a groove once a minute
and very hard for me to get into a
groove before him and but I find the
purging is very very important I find
that I run things and of course this is
you understand this is circular because
I know I'm gonna write a journal I run
in my head what I'm gonna write in the
journal so we don't have the the control
group of if I didn't keep a journal if I
would do this but that being said I I
find it very easy once I've typed out
what happened the day before to
completely forget it it just goes away
the day before it just goes away from me
and I also as I go through my day I act
upon what happened the past 24 hours
right so I make notes for my podcast I'm
going to talk about in Sunday school all
that goes over here and I say oh yeah
yeah I was supposed to write an email to
tell her about this oh yeah yeah and
that bit sucked last night I have to
talk to so-and-so about the prop and oh
yeah yeah yeah my car
I have to I have to talk to somebody
about that you know it becomes a to-do
list before the list happens you know I
mean I asked I'm going I go oh yeah what
was it what happened during the show
last night oh yeah there's this this and
this and then some of those things many
of those things I don't write down but
the going through the the past 24 hours
gives me the focus that reminds me of
things I have to do and then those get
put into their proper files and and
dealt with their proper emails probably
if I just sat down for 20 minutes every
morning and thought about the day before
and what I had to do it would accomplish
the same thing but without the without
the being unstuck in time I'm very very
interested in time travel and how we can
do that emotionally so when I was at
Ringling Brothers when I was hitchhiking
when I was off-broadway I will take a
moment there aren't many of them there
aren't many of them I mean I'm talking
about ten five or ten I'm not talking
about monthly or yearly I will just sit
in a place and try to really be there
and really burn it in so I can then go
back to it so I can go back to a side of
a highway in Nebraska in 1974 the the
pebbles and everything around me I was
looking down at and my sneakers and
everything I can go back there have a
very very very bad visual memory to the
point of being studied by people I can't
imagine anything visually so that's a
very hard thing for me to do other
people can visit stuff in their memories
visually easily but for me it's very
difficult I have a conceptual and verbal
memory and not a visual memory at all I
cannot rotate objects space I cannot
recreate any room I've been in I cannot
do anything so that's a very important
thing and my journal is actually better
than video to me because I don't react
very much to visual so my journal is
really what I was thinking about and how
the world seemed to be emotionally it's
my it's my narrative so the fact that
it's not
accurate recording is actually a plus
but it allows me to move emotionally
through my life you know our teller has
said in interviews I've overheard him
that the defining thing about me is how
obsessed I am with the fact that time
flies that time is going away I think
about that all the time and so that
sense of that's what 20 years ago was is
incredibly important to my personality
and who I am but all of that being said
it may be a justification after the fact
the truth may be that it's just a habit
I want to come back to the weak visual
memory because I I suspect that a lot of
people like me are surprised upon
hearing that since one might assume
given that the many aspects of your
profession that you would have an
incredibly strong visual memory is is
how is having a weak visual memory made
you good or better at what you do ever
you just developed compensating
mechanisms to make up for it maybe
that's part of the answer I don't know
but has it helped you in any way to have
a weak visual my compensation is teller
teller has a phenomenal visual memory
and if you watch teller and I work you
can very clearly see that I'm doing a
radio show every bit that I write I
bring to teller as me doing voiceover
from offstage while stuff happens on
stage and then he moves me onto the
stage moves me as part of the action I
you know we we tend to oversimplify you
know I have to make clear to people it's
not that I don't have visual memory it's
that I have a very bad one
and it's not my go-to when I was
hitchhiking and homeless I enrolled
myself in the University of Chicago
psychological testing
I passed myself off as a student to get
five dollars an hour to do all these
tests and they discovered during that
that I was the furthest they've seen in
this particular study these particular
people I've never been able to go back
and find any other because of course
that wasn't under my name
I had the widest spread of intelligence
they'd ever seen my IQ is so low
visually that I would be in a halfway
house if the rest of my IQ was that way
I have a very very good conceptual
memory if I have ideas I can hold on to
them I have a pretty good audio memory
not in terms of texture but in terms
once again of concepts I can memorize a
script very quickly but if you give me I
mean I can tell you how bad it is and
don't be fooled by this by thinking I
don't have face recognition because I do
have face recognition it's just not good
but I prepare myself for who I'm going
to see so if I've met someone
four or five times there's no chance of
me recognizing them when I see them
almost no chance I have to say well you
know I met Tim and I'm gonna see him at
science party and I know that this is
what he looks like and I'll describe you
to myself and that I'm ready to see you
as though someone told me about you but
I was doing a show in Boston and I
should say parenthetically that I'm a
mama's boy I was very close to my mom
and very close to my dad as well I was
very close to my parents and after the
show teller and I have always
that every person in the audience who
wants to meet us so these people who
come up and take pictures and sign
autographs and so on and just talk to us
and that's often you know an hour or an
hour and a half after an hour and a half
show and I'm not looking closely at
people but my mom I didn't know she was
going to be at the show and she came up
and asked for an autograph and I signed
it for her Wow
at which point she said I'm your mother
now I can imagine my mom but but it
takes work therefore if you come to my
house there's an incredible amount of
art and I look at pictures all the time
and I try very hard to throw myself
individual stuff to to compensate but
when they do these studies I remember
they thought I was lying because they
would show me a picture a picture you
know of a scene or a person and then
they would show me another five pictures
one of which was that person or scene
from another angle and asked me which
one I'd seen and no idea and they would
give me a grid of patterns you know and
they would say recreate this grid and I
could do it instantly so what they were
studying was how I was using conceptual
memory to compensate for visual memory
but I mean it's very very funny because
we will be sitting with a builder for
something we're doing in the show and
they will sketch something and say well
this is a overhead view and if you just
rotate it like this you'll see but it's
from the front and you know the crew
would tell her we'll all look at me and
just don't look back at the person and
go a pen can't do that you have to draw
it from the other angle for him so I
have a long list of things I'm keeping
note of just for people listening her
like Ferris I can't believe you let that
go by and didn't grab it so I want to
talk about
we're gonna talk about the fasting I am
gonna ask you about the homelessness but
before we get there I want to ask you
about dreaming if you have dream recall
what what does the content of your
dreams look or feel like well here we
have the problem of you know seedling
across the ships and a storm you know we
we we don't know what it's like you know
our theory of mind we don't know what
it's like to be someone else right so it
takes a very long time to realize you
know I'm very good friends with Renee
French who's a wonderful artist who can
draw everybody in her kindergarten class
from memory right she can sketch
anything she's seen and we sit around
Renee and I and study each other like
she will say to me does your prop person
that you see every day does he wear
glasses and the truth of the matter is
if we haven't talked about glasses I
don't know and then I'll say to her you
know you've you know you've heard I am
The Walrus a thousand times in your life
what's the third verse and still say I
know no lyrics I am The Walrus except I
have the walrus it's my entire knowledge
of the lyrics of that and we'll talk
about you know he's very very good at
math and she'll talk about how she sees
numbers as colors and spaces that can
manipulate them and I have no idea what
she's talking about
so this is all coming around to the
dreams I experienced my dreams the way I
experienced my life I actually dreamed
that in a very surreal way that I was I
was talking to you and
it was this weird interview situation
and I can tell you what that felt like
and I could tell you that I knew where
people were standing and so on but I
cannot even if I could draw well I could
not sketch a picture of that it's it's
all as though it were elaborately
described to me you know when you talk
about I do meditation and when in the
Sam Harris meditation he talks about
bringing someone's face to mind the
struggle that is is amazing when people
talk about horrific images they've seen
and how they flash back on them I don't
really know what that means now what I
said I don't know what that means
you know I it's just that I am trapped
like you are inside of myself so you
know I know that I my memories involve
me in the third person like most
people's do our manager Glenn all his
memories are don't have him in it he
sees his hands he sees it what's in
front of him which I know is very
unusual but I what I'm able to conjure
up a visual memory see it from a point
of view that I never saw it at I see it
I see myself in it and if I fixture
myself yeah so uh and I know that's most
people see themselves in it I just don't
see it I don't see it clearly there's
also the thing is I've been partners
with teller for 44 years
so things that I might have developed
anything tellers really good at I am not
good at it's just atrophied and tell
it's not good at cuz it's also at rest
so as weak as we become more symbiotic
you know we've we've so the thing is we
don't know yeah well I would have chosen
to be a magician if not for teller so
that's that's that's a that's a silly
thing but um
I don't know if I would have developed
any sort of visualization skills better
if I didn't have a partner that was so
good at it you know I don't I don't pay
any attention to lighting I pay no
attention to set I pay no attention to
anything now if I were doing a solo show
some of that would be required
you know I we would probably guess that
I'd have someone else that I trusted
that would do some of that but you know
once again we don't have a control group
mm-hmm I have to scratch the itch on the
homelessness why were you homeless and
for how well it was for choice homeless
there's really isn't a word for it now
because homeless has become synonymous
with with mentally ill or
poverty-stricken but when I was 18 I was
obsessed as I am now with Bob Dylan and
Bob Dylan had left home hitchhiked jump
hop trains worked at a carnival and
traveled all over the country turns out
none of that was true but I believed it
so all the stuff that Bob Dylan says he
did I actually did including hopping
trains now when I say I was homeless I
called my mother and father every day to
tell them I was okay that is not what
you picture for a homeless person I at
all times had $100 sewn into my backpack
also not true you know for homeless
people I've never had a sip of alcohol
or any recreational drug in my life
very unusual for especially homeless
youth I had a passport with me and a
notarized note from my parents but I did
not have a place to live and I did not
have a job and I hitchhiked and hop
trains all the time how did my parents
allow this I have no idea
the
pasady they had for love and support and
freedom is beyond my understanding but
my mom dropped me off at the rotary as
you can tell him from Massachusetts the
rotary near our home and I got on route
91 and I hitchhiked in during that time
I would stop and stay with friends I
would stop colleges and find a sex
partner that I could stay with and take
classes you know audit classes walk in
it didn't make me difference I was I was
19
you know I had hair down the middle of
my back I was indistinguishable from a
college student so I could go and you
know go to whatever college I wanted to
and sit in on classes I would juggle
I would tell jokes I would pass the Hat
I would make money
I was I was thin you know I didn't need
to eat that often there was nothing to
spend money on hitchhiking was I still
don't understand why it's not more
common nowadays since the world is safer
but I think that because of information
we think the world is more dangerous but
it's you know it's it's certainly an
order of magnitude safer by any measure
than it was when I was hitchhiking and
it was very very safe when I was
hitchhiking
countries are really safe plays I don't
have any fear of it and I hitchhiked
probably I don't know five times across
the country with wise you know four or
five times lengthwise up through Canada
and then during that time I also was
that bringing their brothers barnum
barely greatest show on earth Clown
College
I was street performing occasionally
work at a fair or carnival and then
finally when I when I teamed up with
teller you know I started living in an
apartment but it was it was a gradual
thing
and I was very happy that way the other
thing is that very shortly I became a
successful street performer so by the
time I was the end of my homeless period
I was making several grand a week street
performing that was all in cash so it
was I was a very wealthy homeless person
what was your what constituted your
street performance at the time I would
do crowd gathered the teller still
claims that the greatest thing I've ever
written was my street act he thinks I
haven't come I haven't hit that rest of
my life I would gather crowd using
techniques that are still used that I
created I would gather a crowd of I mean
three or four hundred maybe five hundred
people and I would the crowd gathering
itself would take about five minutes the
collection of money would take about
five minutes and I would do five minutes
in between was about 15 minutes only
five minutes of which were the show the
rest was I guess you would call meta and
I would juggle and I would juggle balls
and I would juggle knives and I was a at
that time very good juggler and my
absolute peak of where I was juggling
when I was practicing eight hours a day
six days a week with mic motion you know
MacArthur grant genius juggler we were
practicing all the time at our absolute
best and we were among the best in the
world we would not even be considered
bush-league nowadays it's just amazing
one of the things that as far as I know
nobody predicted is that the internet
would make juggling better you know it's
amazing I mean really a a
thirteen-year-old who's been juggling
three years would now be better than I
was at my best at my peak if I could
I a little bit on the techniques that
you created for gathering groups of
people could you give one example of one
ingredient of yeah what you might do I
would walk over to three or four people
and say hi I'm gonna be doing a juggling
show here in a few minutes and it'll be
stupid without a crowd so I need to get
a crowd here and I need you to help me
get a crowd so what we're gonna do is
I'm gonna do nothing and then you people
cheer and applaud a little bit even
there's only four or five of you and
then other people around will see you
and they'll think something's happening
and they'll come over here and of course
nothing will be happening and you can
turn around and laugh at them I said
this is just gonna be kind of a joke
we'll play so I would do that and I
would do aggressively nothing
how would you stand there no jokes
nothing they would do that and by that
time first time around I'd be working
like head out square in Philly or I
would only work places where it was
illegal I refused to sign up anywhere
and that would get me to a couple dozen
people then I would do a much bigger
version of that same thing we're gonna
see if we can get 150 people over here
within the next minute and then I would
go to full-out screaming maybe someone's
been hurt get over here you don't want
to miss it there's a big thing happening
and then you would have about a hundred
people laughing at about a hundred
people that were running now running
towards me and then we would get all
those people in and I would do that once
more until the original people that
started were now at an enormous crowd
which they found you know supernaturally
funny it was just so bad and so goofy
and then I would end my show by saying
you know you people in the very back row
you didn't get to see any of the show I
don't expect any money from you at all
that would be foolish for you to give me
money when you haven't seen the show
what I do expect you to do
is hold hands and let nobody out who has
not given you money you people are now
my theatre and that I had a lot of stuff
that that went there and I also had all
sorts of rules that I followed I would
not look in any way needy the
best-dressed I've ever been most
expensively was when I was doing street
performing I wore a $3,000 watch my idea
was that people should be ashamed to
give me less than a 20 and I also you
know you're talking to me in the morning
you hear me clearing my throat and
coughing working outdoors with no
training for 500 people and screaming
covered my my larynx with scar tissue
and made it so that for years I was you
know coughing up blood and drinking
Chloraseptic um for an anesthetic on my
on my throat and the sound of my voice
now is the sound that you get from doing
years of street performing and blowing
it out every day because you know if
you're gonna be out outdoors in the wind
and you got five other people listening
to you to be heard in the back takes
every single thing you have I mean a 15
minute show was completely exhausting so
it sounds like even though you say was
five minutes performing and really the
gathering and asking for money
performance absolute that I didn't I
didn't mean to misrepresent that yes it
was a fifteen minutes show there was no
doubt about it and every single person
was aware of that no one thought like oh
the juggling is over I guess there's no
fun coming everybody knew that the
collection of money was going to be more
fun than the juggling everybody knew
that I mean it was it did not take it
did not take any sort of insight to go
oh what this guy is doing is doing a
show about streets
this genius did you did you take
anything from that period of vagabonding
aside from the development of the street
performing that then led to things that
came later were there other realizations
or anything else that came from that
period that informed your life in a
significant way yeah I mean everything I
got to be phenomenally trusting I
believe that atheism and libertarianism
come from pathological optimism which I
have I found myself you know at at 2:00
in the morning rest stops where I could
easily be beaten to death I found myself
in inner-city places and I even and I
mean this is saying exactly the opposite
of what I should be saying but I don't
know how it fits in
I had no guns pulled on me knives pulled
on me and I was in the worst kind of
situation and it was okay and I came out
of that very trusting of people I also
came out of it being incredibly good at
de-escalating hostility very odd thing
happened to me where I did two tours of
duty on Celebrity Apprentice and I was
on there with people who were volatile
and there was one time after it aired
you know there's that there's that big
lag in television so it was like six
months after it happened and I don't
ever watch myself on TV so I hadn't seen
the show but we got a call from an FBI
guy at our office and the FBI guy wanted
to talk to me and of course the first
reaction you should have when the FBI
calls you is to lawyer up
our manager said what do you why do you
want to talk to Penn and they assured
him it was nothing nothing criminal
which the FBI does even what it is
something criminal so we were still a
little wary but the guy then got my
email address and wrote to me and said
that he had watched an altercation
between me and Lou Ferrigno on Celebrity
Apprentice on the television show on TV
and that Lou Ferrigno was was becoming
very aggressive to me and the the guy
Quantico said it's really interesting
that you followed all that we teach our
FBI guys on how to defuse a situation
your eye contact your body language your
calmness without backing down he had a
whole list of things he said you do
every one of them in order and you
defuse the situation completely and he
said we want to know where you study
this and I said well you know I I lived
a hitchhiking for quite a while and
you'd find yourself in a you know in a
biker bar you know with long hair and
wear and eye makeup and you'd find
yourself with somebody that didn't like
that and I said I've never hit anybody
in anger in my life ever
I am completely a pacifist I'm
completely nonviolent and I have been
around very violent people and I never
wanted them to go a step further and he
said you come would you come in to speak
it quantico about defeat I said no yes
hold position you fool I don't know
anything you go to study this and teach
clean-cut people with guns to do it but
I I said I think being a clean-cut
person with a gun makes this harder to
do actually but no but I'm so flattered
it's so amazing so I think that I
carried that through
you know I have done some very
transgressive performing and I don't get
beat up much because this is a very
valuable skill could you give an example
of how you de-escalated a situation and
what the steps or strategies were that
you used could be with Lou could be with
anyone but just an example oh how you
deescalate in a situation well I don't
really because I didn't learn it because
I developed at trial and error I don't
really have a checklist I go through but
I can tell you one story I was in
somewhere like Nebraska and this was
early on hitchhiking I was you know 18
maybe and did not have a lot of money at
that point and I did have very long hair
and very eccentric clothes and I mean I
was a hippie and it was it was 73 and
history hasn't shown it but the 60s
actually happened in the early 70s you
know 68 there you know it wasn't until
70s that the hippie movement hit their
rural areas really and there were still
a lot of fear and aggression towards
people with long hair even as late as 73
and I was in a diner and I was flirting
with the waitress
and it was the I'm sorry server it was
the middle of the night and a little
counter little tiny diner and I had
ordered a milkshake and a piece of pie
which was my entire diet for weeks then
and that was all the money I happened to
have at that point was to buy a
milkshake an ax and a piece of pie and
leave a tip which I always did because I
was a street performer and so I put my
whatever that was three dollars down for
that you know you got to figure what
inflation is about add a zero to it so
that's about thirty dollars nowadays I
bought my milkshake um I had one of
those really good ones it's in the cam
the whole thing when it used to be a
friend the best the best yeah and two
guys driving a truck two separate trucks
came in and they were not in the mood to
see a hippie and they were also you know
that was also tied in at that time with
sexual preference you know they're gonna
call me things like homosexual slurs and
so on and they're gonna confuse the
politics and the sexuality and so
they're there they're getting very very
aggressive and they're also showing off
in front of the server who was
attractive and they're coming in towards
me and they're very very clearly going
to hit me it's escalating very very
quickly and so I said wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute women and I
picked up my milkshake the glass in one
hand and the metal container in the
other and I poured them over my head in
front of him just picked him up and
poured cold sticky milkshake over my
head and they then said and I'm gonna
use another slur here please forgive me
they then said he's just [ __ ] they
weren't gonna hit somebody who was
covered with milkshake it wasn't gonna
make them appear macho so they actually
just grabbed their coffee to go and got
in their truck and left and the server
was rather impressed and I said yeah I I
did defuse the situation but nob covered
in milkshake and then I had to go in to
the restroom at this little diner and
try to clean my clothes and my hair and
everything of milkshake in a dirty sink
and then came back out she was
very kind the guy who was a short-order
cook in the back came out and they gave
me another piece of pie and another
milkshake on the house and I remember
smelling the milkshake in my hair for
about 48 hours but that is a clear case
of how you can stop someone from hitting
you now you have to you know have no ego
involved in this at all you can't say I
want to prove well actually that's not
true I feel in telling the story in my
narrative I proved I was a genius but to
them I didn't prove that right Wow
I want to talk about defuse the
situation is very simply to give the
other side everything they want I mean
right yeah ah yes I'm a dirty filthy
hippie I'm an awful person I know I'm
this I'm at if if you don't have if you
don't fall into the macho trap of I have
to prove something to a stranger about
my might my intellect my morality or my
sexuality
if those just go away and aren't
important you have diffused what 70% of
those situations and if you're not
drinking
you've diffused a hundred percent of
them yeah yeah you know you know if you
go to any trauma unit and ask them what
percentage of people in here have
alcohol or drugs part of their problem
they will tell you a hundred percent
if you move sober through the world you
have this huge advantage right you know
I mean just a remarkable advantage
because you can make kind of rational
decisions and you don't have certain
certain parts of your thinking reduced
you know so I've read about your
abstinence from alcohol and drugs and so
on and the you can't believe everything
you read on the Internet of course but
the the line that popped out at me may
be true maybe not is that you feel you
have an addictive person
and therefore you didn't do these things
has that always been the case and how
did you if that's true how did you come
to that conclusion to begin with well I
have five or six narratives for the not
drinking and not doing drugs that are
you know I don't have access to why I
really do stuff any more than anyone
else does
I do know that I come from a long line
of teetotalers and if you look at any
sort of data parents not doing drugs and
not drinking is the biggest indicator of
offspring not doing drugs and drinking
now a lot of that's tied in with a
certain sort of cults and so on
fundamentalist things so that that date
is confused but the fact that my mom and
dad never mentioned drugs or alcohol
that it was never in the house they
never told me not to do it it just did
not exist in my world I remember talking
to my buddy Christopher Hitchens who
drank a lot and we had there was a lot
of discussion over that being friends
one of whom drank heavily a mono track
not at all and one time I said to him
and it seemed pretty heavy I said when
you think of someone drinking who do you
picture that he said Winston Churchill
and I said oh that's interesting he said
who do you picture I said Ronny parantha
and Christopher Hitchens who knew
everything went crazy trying to figure
out trying to remember who Ronny pronto
was and I said you know you don't know
him he wrapped his car around a tree
when I was in high school so the first
people I saw drink the first people I
saw drink were 12 year olds 13 year olds
vomiting on themselves the first people
other people saw drink or adults
interacting in a sane way I think that's
part of it the other part of it is I've
always wanted to be smarter than I am
and what I saw people doing drugs and
alcohol they didn't seem like they were
smarter than they were they seemed
stupider I now know that you can make
the argument Joe Rogan can make the
argument and Sam Harris to make the
argument there was certain so I could
that may not be true but let's let's not
go there at this answer and then the
other thing was I was obsessed all I
wanted when I was in junior high in high
school was to be Jewish gay and live in
New York City
but I was a big dumb farm boy you know I
wanted to be I wanted to be five seven
five eight I wanted to have a enormous
nose I wanted and I wanted to talk with
a lisp and I wanted to live in the
village that's all I wanted and I loved
Lenny Bruce and then Lenny Bruce was
dead before I knew about it I only knew
the records and my understanding of him
was that drugs killed him I loved
Hendrix and drugs killed him and I
wanted to pursue a life in the arts
which I'd never met anybody in the arts
in my little town never met one person
in the arts but I wanted to do that and
I felt that people with my personality
seemed and this I realized it's
incredibly pretentious and presumptuous
and forgive me but my self-image was
such but I tried to find parts of my
heart that overlap with Lenny Bruce I'm
not saying now but I'm at that talented
a level but as a child I wanted to be
that and I thought boy if I want to be
that that sure kills a lot of people
that have this personality type and I
also knew that I did not respect
moderation in any way I wanted to be all
or nothing on everything and I just
thought if I had one sip of alcohol
I would be mainlining heroin within a
week I really felt that so let's add
yeah you have a lot of proof points for
that for the intensity at least but that
dislike of moderation right I mean this
is not unfounded
look I'm sorry to interrupt but I have
to ask because people are gonna want to
hear about and I want to hear about it
uh it's kind of segwaying from the
dislike of moderation let's talk about
your weight loss exceptionally hardcore
I Nev but I wanted to correct me if I'm
wrong that this this really sort of had
rocket fuel poured on it late 2014
something like that but how much just
just as a starting point how much weight
did you lose over what period of time if
you want the real metrics I lost an
average of 0.9 pounds a day for four
months that's the average 0.9 which is
pretty amazing if you look at the whole
thing you know we tend not to weigh
ourselves at the heaviest so I don't
really have the metric but I know that I
have an actual data point at like 335
you know 340 you know I have that actual
data point I probably was higher than
that I probably was maybe 10 maybe 15
pounds higher than that and at my lowest
which was on my birthday you know cray
ray ray Crowe nice you write in your
book about him yeah this is all right
Hurk Ray Ray as I call them this is all
grey ray and in what I believe is
difficult mathematics as landing a man
on the moon he was able to predict my
weight four months in advance to within
two tenths of a pound that's incredible
yes but he also says that in his
experience I am the only one that has
followed every rule without one
deviation point for
hold on okay so let's pause for one
second because I want to give people
context honoré so great read and realize
he called him that rake fro nice CRO n
is a former NASA scientist I met a long
time ago something like 2007-2008 at
NASA Ames Research Center in Mountain
View California
and I wanted to talk to him because a
mutual friend had described
experimentation he had done using cold
exposure to accelerate fat loss and he
mentioned the thermodynamics earlier ray
knows a lot about thermodynamics and he
then became the profile for a chapter in
the 4-hour body about using cold
exposure to accelerate fat loss and body
recomposition what worse about his
thinking in his approaches have
developed over time and he's added a lot
more to the toolkit what were some of
the rules that that he had you follow
well both ray and I are atheists and
skeptics and we did a really interesting
thing grey ray said you know we know
that there are things that work in
joining a cult and we also know that we
can access things that we know are wrong
to modify behaviors so he said you are
going to decide to join my cult for this
amount of time and you were gonna follow
cult rules and we both know they're
[ __ ] but we're doing them just for
fun he said you're not gonna talk to
anybody about what you're doing you are
gonna cut off your family and friends
from this you are going to do whatever I
say
absolutely and without question and you
are going to deal with me as though I
had complete power now you and I know
Penn that at least half of what I think
about this is wrong we just don't know
what half we don't know what parts so
you're just going to go along with it
and you're gonna use all that occult
stuff here's what you're gonna do first
two weeks you're eating that
but potatoes and that is going to knock
you out of your social eating and that
is going to let you feel what hunger
feels like and that's going to let you
see what the advertising looks like that
will take the blinders away and then
we're gonna add in food and this is what
you will eat every day up until here and
you are allowed none of this this this
this or this
and I guess you want to hear what that
is so I did potatoes for two weeks then
we added in some beans and chili and
some rice and vegetables and salads and
it was four months before I had a taste
of fruit or nuts and he also allowed me
to not think that this was going to be
forever you know oh you'll have a steak
again you'll have steak you'll have all
that but for right now we're just gonna
do this and he also and I can't stress
how important this is and I think you've
discovered this a lot in your work as
well but every time I tried to lose
weight before every [ __ ] doctor every
article the New York Times had always
said this is an easy way to weight loss
this is the easy way to weight loss and
it was like it as Brando says in
Apocalypse like a diamond bullet my
forehead when I say simple exchange with
Ray and I said to him so I could I can
lose like 40 pounds easily you wouldn't
know it's gonna be really really hard
[Laughter]
and I went oh no one had ever said that
to me before no one yeah it always said
you're gonna cut down your portions a
little bit you'll have a small a bit of
dessert and you'll lose a pound a week
over the next 150 years you know nice
and slow and easy you won't even know
this pan you won't even notice and I'm
and he said oh it's gonna be really hard
and I realized in that instant that no
brags about walking up a grassy slope
they brag about climbing Everest you
know I have never ever want to do
anything easy in my life why with my
health was I decided that that was the
thing that had to be easy and I realized
that I not only do I not respect
moderation I don't respect people who
have moderation you know I want you know
I mean want to quote the Kerouac here I
want the people that the madmen who
burst into flames that's who I wanna you
know oh I want to love and and so you
know he had me to contrast showers you
know hot to cold back and forth
he had me he had me eat potatoes
whenever I wanted but then I went down
to very strict amounts of time and there
were things that I think were probably
borderline irresponsible we cut down my
calorie intake enough that I was
lightheaded
probably too much of the time but it was
okay you know it ended up alright and
what we really do you can always do the
arithmetic you know Cray ray doesn't
care at all about calories and I don't
count calories and I don't care at all
but you want to do the arithmetic you
can say what point nine pounds a day in
terms of calories are you know so we can
probably say I was eating four to five
thousand calories a day and we cut it
back to probably six hundred you know
we're talking about very very but here
is the thing that I'm most embarrassed
about and also kind of like you often
are where the Bears things most proud of
having learned being an atheist I did
not believe in mind-body duality I did
not believe there was a spirit I
believed that I was my body and that all
by thinking and all my love and all my
awareness and all bike
consciousness so but nobody knows what
consciousness is but all of that did
have an organic place I I believe that
completely or so I thought
and when I started losing the weight and
my mood started changing I mean they
were psychological changes in me I
became gentler kinder and let's
underline this and put it in all caps
happier and this is from someone who was
not depressed who was very very happy
who didn't have any problems that wasn't
violent it wasn't any of that but still
wherever you are you can go up further
you know and I realized that I did not
believe the organic view of humanity
completely I had this sense that there
was a homunculus driving myself behind
my eyeballs that was kind of my spirit
that didn't care that it was functioning
in a fat body uh and as I started to
lose that weight I went oh yeah I get it
I mean in a certain sense I'm thinking
and feeling with my whole body it's not
just this lump of brain inside my head
and that was a phenomenal thing to
realize how wrong I had been you know
there was there was a weird thing you
know but I went to the Vomit Comet also
because of cray ray did he brag about
knowing them in 2000 I know in the 90s I
went on the vomit
so I went from weightless to double my
way in approximately thirty second
intervals like 26 seconds or something
and I did a lot of parabolas I did
because I was you know I was under the
legal flight and it was it was all very
illegal and we were doing so we did like
you know 40 parabolas Samas weightless
for a long time and I was heavy for a
long time I was heavy at that time was
fat then too and I went to twice my way
and what I remembered later was that
when I went to twice my weight my mood
changed it's incredible how you can you
can learn what weight loss will do to
you emotionally by going in the Vomit
Comet and going from as I was going from
0 to 600 pounds back and forth and one
minute intervals and it's amazing how
when you're heavier you get sadder now I
don't know if this directly maps onto it
that this may be more poetic than
scientific I don't want to make claims
don't really understand but I as I lost
weight I lost weight I lost concerns
things were lighter things were easier I
didn't have to think about wanting to
play with my children you know oh I
should do this I just did it and it was
really it was really remarkable
remarkable changes in my life you know
and I have also you know since then I've
done a two-week fast I guess I have to
underline medically supervised and
because I don't want anybody to think
they can just do that it's not safe and
three days you're safe but over three
days be careful
and I've also gained weight since then
and now now I'm going down again
but I have made you know the magic
moment is two years everybody gains back
their weight in two years and if you
don't gain back the weight in two years
you are in this very small percentage
it's set different sunny state different
amounts but two to five percent people
keep it off after two years and what
gray Rays discovering which someone of
your build doesn't get to discover this
but the faster you lose the weight the
more likely you are to keep it off which
is contrary to everything that we
believed five years ago you know so uh
it's worked well for me and you
mentioned the extended fast the 14-day
fast you have you've also found a place
for as we mentioned before recording
people in Silicon Valley and elsewhere
would call intermittent fasting it but
it sounds like your current default when
you are behaving is roughly twenty three
hours of fasting one hour of eating per
day and I will tell you that if you were
to sit down with me during that one hour
of feeding you would be appalled the
actual volume of food that I eat is
phenomenal I mean I eat a salad the size
of your head
you know i jegg antics salad I eat
probably six servings of brown rice or
some whole grain you know of Pharaoh or
one of those things I try to eat a
little less brown rice it's little less
healthy that's my favorite food in the
world
you know chili beans do you know maybe
even some fat stuff like guacamole
my wife is incredible vegan cook and
follows I follow the Fuhrman thing
absolutely incredibly low salt credibly
low oil really very little processed and
then the amount of fruit that I have for
dessert is you know those containers of
blueberries like five of those and like
two cups
granites uncie's on top of those I mean
a gigantic bull would not fit any bowl
you have has to be like an industrial
bowl that I'm meeting on it's just that
mixing ball like Michael Jordan eating
banana pudding you know it's that of
food and that usually a few squares of
incredibly dark 90% chocolate and that
is really an hour of evening you know my
children join me for supper about 15
minutes and I'd leave before half hours
I still have a half hour to go and you
know it's one of the reasons I can't eat
at restaurants is I can't get the volume
of food we're really talking about the
equivalent I mean to put this in terms
that are kind of easy to visualize I
probably eat the equivalent of like
eight baked potatoes you know it's a
huge amount but then again if you're
looking at caloric content or fat
content or any of that it's really low
and what my body is trying to do is to
desperately get you know whatever I need
a day you know whatever that is 15 to
2,000 calories trying to get that out of
incredibly uh not nutrient a nutrient
rich but not calorie rich food and and
also I'm very fortunate I mean I we give
a lot of credit to cram but also my wife
who's been you know not eating mammals
for years and years and as takes cooking
very seriously
and really enjoyed the Fuhrman challenge
I eat really different food every single
night and it's always gourmet quality
and you know dr. Klapper
his head supper with me and and Cray
race had supper many times with me and
they're just blown away they just go you
know with this kind of food delivered to
you every night anyone can do this
there's nothing required it's just
incredibly incredibly good food that's
that's you know labor-intensive and when
I go on the road and I go down to just
eating you know you know 10 containers
of watermelon and had had and rice and
beans and stuff plain it's it's it's
fine
but then again that's that's rare for me
and then you know there is all I really
want to eat which is peanut butter if I
had my way I would eat nothing but pain
of butter all day all night all the time
the other thing that blew my mind and I
you know you read these books on habit
and I read this book one bite or first
bite I think really great book and this
woman set out to find what scientists
believe that food desires were innate
and what scientists believed that food
desires were learned cultural individual
and she couldn't find any scientists
that believed it was an 8 it is
incredible how I thought that foods that
I absolutely loved are now repulsive to
me just because they're out of habit you
know things I mean my favorite foods I
now look at and go even uncomfortable
watching other people eat them and my
new comfort foods have just changed
there's a lot of stuff you don't know
anything about this but you know your
microbiome changes over 3 or 4 months
there's certainly feedback to the brain
from the microbiome we know that
although it's in its infancy and all of
that stuff you know when you read those
scientific articles all of that stuff
completely maps over my first-hand
experience please don't allow me to
claim stuff I don't know I'd like very
much to talk about how the microbiome
changed my personality and all of that
but I can't prove that I have no
evidence so don't let me go there but
what I feel about is that my diet has
changed me profoundly but listen at the
same time I started meditating and other
stuff changed in my life
so we don't we don't have that control
we'd never have a control of our own
lives
yeah one of the big challenges of a
multifactorial life outside of the
laboratory it's it's tough and I want to
I really congratulate you on the weight
not just the weight loss but also
inspiring people to pursue better health
as an example of what can be done it's I
know that a lot of people have lost a
lot of weight after seeing you so
publicly take better control of your
health so it's it's it's really yeah
well it's remarkably I I also want to
say and this is the part that you might
quibble with and I'd be interested
creare also allowed no exercise
whatsoever during the time I was losing
weight
he believes that weight loss and
bodybuilding who fight each other and
that you should not be doing great
exertion you should be sitting you
should be doing very little when you're
doing weight loss and people have
misunderstood that as you know Penn's
miraculous just eat potatoes and don't
exercise diet which you know very well
but I want to say it is very contrary to
what I did I eat a full rounded full
meals for two weeks I did potatoes as a
stunt to teach myself things about food
it was not done as a healthy diet it's
not done for a lifetime it's done for
two weeks
and then not exercising was not done for
a lifetime it was done for that time
while I wanted to take a lot of weight
off and then exercise starts back in
yeah so let me let me respond to that
because Ray and I meet I died on a lot
of things and I don't think we're as far
away as as one might suspect the I do
think that exercise can act as a lead
domino that then causes just through
cognitive dissonance better behavior
when it comes to diet but Ray is right I
think and I don't want to speak for him
but I can only speak to my position and
that is
you cannot outwork your mouth and yes
there is one of the common consequence
you want to call them exactly it you
can't outrun your mouth yeah oh I'm just
yeah I'm not even necessarily quoting I
but but it's it's very common mistake
that when you take someone who is
accustomed to overeating who then layers
on exercise that is not necessarily
building muscle mass but gives the
creates the illusion of great energy
expenditure say certain types of
cardiovascular exercise that they
compensate by rewarding themselves with
ten times the number of calories that
they would have burned in that given
session so I I do think there's a place
for resistance training I don't think it
has to be frequent but that in the
beginning it is really important to make
the primary focus dietary so people
understand that you if you want to
change the musculature that is attached
to your skeletal system you do that by
lifting weights if you want to really
lose body fat for body recomposition
it is 90% plus diet and you you have to
prove that to yourself in a very
effective way of doing that is taking
exercise off the table for a short
period of time in which span you can
prove to yourself quite easily that you
you lose pounds in the kitchen not
primarily in the gym so I I do I do
agree with them I I think in principle
on that well everything you just said is
right in line I think that there was
certainly a way the other thing is that
that I that I should say that I stopped
exercise but I didn't stop doing this
show and Ray strapped on one of those
calorie counters you know that goes
takes all your breath and everything and
and had me do five minutes of our show
at full volume and full energy and was
astonished by the amount of calories I
was burning so he said you know your
kind
doing a run every night so my no
exercise thing is kind of sort of
[ __ ] that's a great great point so
you have to remember that although I
tell you I was sitting during that time
I was going out on stage and jumping and
running and yelling for 90 minutes every
night and that's even even at a lighter
version of Penn that's still quite a bit
of mass to having a lot of me you're
moving a lot of let's let's talk about
this is a bit of a left turn but that's
okay I'd like to talk about one of my
favorite physicists and because I
certainly never had a chance to meet him
but it sounds like you did and that is
Richard Fineman
yeah I've been fascinated by Fineman for
decades and actually recently ended up
buying a set of his encyclopedias that
he kept in his office Wow but never had
a chance to have any interactions and I
was hoping you could describe your
interactions with Richard or and
anything that you might have taken from
those those encounters with him yeah I
met him a very long time ago it's funny
because there was a show on television
called numbers it was actually spelled
num three years you know it's been a
three in there and the premise was a
mathematician who solves crimes and they
had a scientist who was the consultant
for the television show and I came on
playing myself and one of the script
writers had written in aligned for me
where I talked about being friends with
Richard Fineman and the scientist who
was consulted on the show
flagged it and said I don't think you
want to do this line because there is
really it's a real stretch of the
imagination to believe that Penn
Jillette could could have known Richard
Feinman and I said well I did and he
went oh I said well I did so it's a
stretch of the imagination but not for
it's a memory so they let that line go I
I think read maybe was surely you're
joking as soon as it came out and I was
a big fan of Richard Feynman and we were
doing a show at the Las Palmas the the
LA stage company is called now in
Hollywood about a 500 seat theater and
we had done this list in our program of
people we'd like to see the show it was
a funny kind of idea we have he's a list
of like 50 names that included you know
Samuel Beckett and George Romero and
Richard Fineman and Debbie Harry and Lou
Reed were on this list of people it just
said people would like to have see our
show that was it and 5 it was on the
list and Crispin Glover was on the list
and fireman came to the show and we
ended the show at that time with my
favorite monologue I've ever written
that my favorite to do which the thing
we call ten and one which is what the
carnival sideshow is actually called
among the carnival people is ten and one
where I describe the physics of fire
eating the biology of fire reading I
teach fire eating then perform it and
during that time I talk about how we
think that skeptics are against the
mystery whereas it's religious people
are against the mystery religious people
see a mystery and they want to have an
answer this is how things happen and so
on I do it much better in the real model
life but I can't get into it this way
and scientists are willing to say I
don't know
and that's embracing the mystery and lo
and behold Richard Fineman connected me
after one of the shows and said that I
had said something in that monologue
that he had never been able to say that
clearly and that he had brought his wife
and he had said to her afterwards see
that's what I mean
and she'd understood
that she hadn't understood before were
they I mean a mind-blowing thing to have
said to somebody you know I was pretty
pretty much fell apart and then over the
next run of the show he came back to the
show several times and at one point he
brought five count them five Nobel
laureates with him to see a show we may
have had the highest concentration of
Nobel laureates outside of Stockholm at
the LA stage company and became friends
I think would be would be exaggerating
but I had his home phone number and we
went out to dinner a few times and I met
Murray gell-mann and talked with him to
show you the clash of cultures Murray
gell-mann once said to me I've heard
there's a television program on late at
night hosted by David Letterman that
might be a good move for your career for
you to go on Letterman yeah exactly and
that and so the story I tell that makes
science friends of mine bang their head
against the wall is I would pick up
fireman's books on physics and I would
realize that I because I got out of high
school on a plea bargain and didn't
really graduate I didn't know the
algebra for you know he would explain
something I get it so I would call him
up say hey Richard I've read in your
book here this whole paragraph here I I
get trouble with it and he would say
well that's just your high school
algebra pen my slide I didn't have high
school algebra he would say okay get a
piece of paper
at a pencil and let's go through high
school out sound credible and I had the
full with them for like you know an hour
and a half where he'd be going so you
cancel out the a what that side of the
equals side you cancel it out over there
you know and I beat arithmetic he was
teaching you arithmetic and I'd get
through his book and I'd call him up and
say I get a few questions about vectors
there you go okay shoot just you can
omit and then perhaps the funniest was
teller and I wanted to do a bit on
Letterman with liquid-air we wanted
liquid nitrogen you know and the gag was
were gonna drop things in and freeze
them and smash them and then tell his
hand was gonna go in and would smash his
hand and then we drop a mouse in and
then show the mouse was okay and then
the mouse would would jump in and that
was the gank so we needed to have a lot
of liquid nitrogen we needed to play
around with it and at that time I mean
it's amazing how stupid I was I was in
the 80s I didn't know what what you
could do with liquid nitrogen or where
to get it
so teller said well we gotta find a
physicist to get on board to help us
with this liquid nitrogen thing and I
said well I'll call Fineman so I called
Richard I said listen man we want to do
this bit on Letterman we want to do
liquid nitrogen we want to do a liquid
air show and he went off [ __ ] I I
haven't dealt with any like real physics
in 50 years I don't know I don't know I
so I don't know I don't know what to do
and firemen said well let me get on it
you know and like an hour later
professor called me from a Community
College in Brooklyn yes and he said the
I speak to Penn Jillette please I said
yeah this is Penn he said I know this is
a gag I know this is a practical joke
but someone claiming to be Richard
Fineman called me
and asked me if I would call pen of
petted teller to set up a liquid air
show on Letterman I know I'm the brunt
of the joke I just don't know what the
joke is
who is this and who called me I said
well this is pen and it was Richard fine
then they called called you and he just
but I get a call from Richard Fineman I
said yes he said where'd he get my
number
I said maybe there's like a directory of
physicists I don't know he said I teach
at a community college I said what so we
got together with that guy and we worked
with him for three weeks and did the
liquid-air show on on Letterman which is
a bit that went very well and the guy
brought a ton of liquid nitrogen we said
you know tell us the stuff you do when
it's not in front of school classes the
stuff that's a little bit too dangerous
and a little bit too crazy and let's
play with it so we played with liquid
nitrogen and even liquid oxygen and all
sorts of stuff for weeks and did a bit
on the show that that went very well but
when I try to tell science friends of
mine that to get liquid nitrogen I
called Richard Fineman they just go we
knew you were an [ __ ] Pam
but yeah her head and then I called
Picasso to ask him where I could buy
some number-two pencils right and you
mentioned a book I just want to
underscore for people because it's such
a fun read surely you're joking mr.
Fineman fe y n ma an is is a as a
fantastic read for people who want to
understand why I get so giddy talking
about Richard Fineman why I'd be so
interested in him not just as a
physicist but also as a teacher right I
mean he was such an incredible teacher
and yeah but more more important than
either of those two is he was he was a
person that you want to you you want to
be I mean Bob Dylan sings to live
outside the law you must be honest
richard fineman had found a way to live
outside the law that was phenomenal he
would not fall into any cliche
whatsoever you know my friend Tim
Jenison who is how I know ray Krone eyes
we did a movie about him called his
Vermeer yeah
spectacular movie by the way Tim thank
you Tim said to me that when he's
meeting somebody if he learns two things
about them and can guess the third he's
really uninterested like if he finds out
that they're vegan and they like the
Grateful Dead and then he finds out
they're against nuclear power
he says I'm kind of done I kind of know
that kind of person and it's really
interesting to look at oneself and say
if someone has two cliched data points
on me can they guess the third to be
absolutely right and Fineman was the
perfect example of that you know you you
you could say Nobel Prize winner you
know professor drummer he wasn't like a
guy listened to opera you know what I
mean he was a drummer and he was a you
know South American style music drummer
he was the way he spoke that we carried
himself
you could not guess what the other thing
was going to be and it's it's one of the
ways probably unfairly that you can
decide how close you want to be to
somebody is just if they can tell you
something really early on that surprises
you you know as we build as we build our
theory of other minds we get these
points and then we guess the other
points and if you can't do that that's
someone you want to fall in love with
definitely and and you I was planning
this was actually the next point was
related to Tim's for here that I wanted
to bring up because it relates to two
Fineman also
in in another respect and that is in
surely you're joking mr. Fineman or may
have been one of his later works richer
talks about learning to paint and having
a debate with his painter friend about
who can better appreciate the flower
right the person who only sees the
extrinsic beauty of observation or the
person who has a better understanding of
the mechanisms underlying the biology
the bot in the underlying the flower
itself and Richard would argue for the
latter having additional layers of
appreciation for this thing they're then
painting and one of the aspects of your
work and your work with teller that I so
appreciate is not just the beauty of the
the trick or the gag but also the beauty
of what comes behind it and I'd love to
hear because you have an infinite number
of projects you could choose from how
did you choose to put the time into
Tim's Vermeer it is one of my favorite
documentaries in the last many years and
I highly recommend everybody check it
out but maybe you could you could I'd
love to hear you explain how you decided
to pursue that oh why because I I
couldn't I couldn't find another way I
didn't want to I did not have the time
and it was not on my agenda to get done
but I had young children very young
children and I realized that I had not
had a conversation with an adult that I
was not outside of my family that I was
not being paid for in a year that really
distressed them so I I called up Tim and
I thought it was a social call he
remembers as an emergency call
and I said hey Tim you know I just gotta
talk to someone and he said okay I'll
fly it so he flew into Vegas and at that
time we were both eating meat which we
don't do now we went to war Texas de
Brazil and sat down I said Tim tell me
something I can't possibly make money on
I can't possibly use in my show and I
don't know him/her and he said how much
you know about earlier and I said first
two paragraphs of Wikipedia and I'm out
and then Tim sat there and then he
pulled out audio-visual aids at that
time you didn't do that with a with a
cell phone as easily he had an actual
video camera with them with a little
screen on it and he showed me his early
experiments with Vermeer and I said boy
Tim you have [ __ ] up royally because
this is something that's involved my
business this should be a documentary
and Tim said no nobody cares about this
at all I said no no the world will care
about this dude he said no no nobody
cares about this this is one scientific
paper no one cares I said no no this is
this is a movie and then I said let's
find you something so I talked to a lot
of producers of a lot of directors Tim
and I flew to LA we flew to New York
actually I was a hinderance because
people thought that his extraordinary
claim was a gag because I was with him
you know that was doing some sort right
this is some sort of hidden camera gag
but you know BBC was a little interested
and I had a couple of good directors
that were a little interested and then I
iced up Tim into my horrible show
business world it needings
in meetings with people that go nowhere
which I'm sure you're very familiar with
I've had it yeah as Jesse Dylan says
every meeting in Hollywood is a month of
your life and finally I was we had
finished like four meetings in New York
we were at some
coffee place and I said Tim you know Tim
[ __ ] it just I don't want to deal with
these people anymore forget about it
let's just do it and he said what do you
mean I said let's put the money up make
the goddamn move and I said because I
would rather spend the money than take
any more of these meetings with dip
shits I can't do it
and Tim said Tim said okay let's go and
he said you're gonna direct it I said
I'm not good at Direct that I can't
direct like I can't visualize things I
can't direct and but I'll produce it
I'll put it all together and Tim said
okay and he said I can do the tech on it
and I'll just buy the cameras I said
okay good and I said let's find a
director and I mean this is this is
embarrassing but of course teller and I
are very frank with each other now there
was my fifth choice to direct it and
finally we went through a few people who
didn't like him it didn't seem right
they didn't get it they didn't have time
and finally tell her do nothing about
any of this we approached teller Tim and
I together and said Tim is doing this
crazy thing we think it should be a
movie what do you think and I be started
on this you know five-year journey of
Tim painted a Vermeer which he tells
everybody over and over again he would
have never finished if not for the movie
he says the moment his blood ran cold
was when he said to tell her you know I
I may not be able to finish this and
then the then there's no movie and tell
her where oh oh the opium movie tip said
it was just the most complete terror
he's ever felt so I really tried very
hard my plan on Tim's Vermeer was after
that night to hand it off to a company
and a producer and a director and just
analyst
I'd cheer and I just I just couldn't
find someone that was easy enough to do
that and you don't tell his plan was for
this to be a pen project you'd have to
worry about that he got sucked into and
now I I mean I have to have to change
the spin I did not want to do it I am
incredibly proud and happy that I did do
III I mean I don't want to add that I
don't want to leave without adding that
could that be disingenuous yeah and and
please please correct me if I get any
this wrong but just to pun intended
paint a little bit of a picture for
people who aren't familiar with the film
so Tim's Vermeer tracks your friend Tim
Jenison who's a very good engineer also
an inventor a general tinkerer of high
intellect who became interested in
johannes vermeer who was this baroque
period painter who achieved
photorealistic effects in his paintings
that that could have defied belief and
follows Tim's attempt to determine how
he made those paintings and to replicate
one himself is that a fair description
yes very much
and it's it is uh it's it's a really
fantastic portrait also pun intended of
not just him but also obsession and so
many things that that to the tickle my
fancy I saw it in the theater something
that I suppose quite a few years ago now
and just just loved it so I know we've
we've had a pretty long conversation
thus far so I don't want to take up too
much more of your time but this has been
so much fun for the planners glad that
we finally got together and I have I
have a whole slew of other things I'd
love to ask you so maybe another time
but I but but I'd like to ask just a few
quick closing questions and these are
these are questions I asked pretty often
sometimes they work sometimes they don't
but
the question is one of what you would
put on a billboard
this is metaphorically speaking if you
could put anything on a billboard
non-commercial it could be a question
quote statement image anything to get
something out to billions of people
that's saying is there anything that
that comes to mind that you would put on
such a billboard Jesus had a swimmer's
body okay can you explain why that's
what you choose there's some reason I've
actually looked into pricing to put that
billboard up it makes me laugh so much
it seems like the perfect absurdist
thing that seems to have a great deal of
poetic depth to me so not you probably
ask this question to people
hypothetically but I actually within the
past six months have looked into prices
for a billboard in Vegas that simply
says Jesus had a swimmer's body how did
this occur I don't know I just struck me
it seems to be just pure pure poetic
view of love of life and atheism okay
that's enough that's enough
I give any any any parting comments
suggestions anything you'd like to say
before we wrap up I'll link to
everything we've talked about in the
show notes for people at tim dot blog
forward slash podcasts so certainly
they'll be able to find you on on
twitter yeah I was called Penn's Sunday
school every Sunday where I talk like
this you know I I don't know you know I
in the age of Trump I've one of the
worst things you know they they say and
I hate to follow you know Godwin's law
here but they say what are the worst
things about Hitler was he turned his
enemies into him and I know Trump very
well
and one of the worst things Trump is
done and the one that I was the farthest
from predicting was what he's done to
the other side the people that really
really dislike Trump for I will add very
good reasons have become so unkind and
so angry and you have stuff like if
you're a trump voter I don't want to
talk to you if you're a Trump voter you
know I was told by what's-his-name Frank
on the the the big pollster that then
had the largest number of Thanksgiving
dinners canceled because relatives did
not want to talk to each other because
of the Trump thing I've been trying to
do this thing which is impossible by the
way and if I'm successful I will simply
go mad but I've been trying this thought
experiment of trying not to use the
words US in them I've tried to say the
sentence those of us who voted for Trump
which is a very difficult sentence to
say but if you say it it's it's very
profound because it is those of us who
voted for Trump it's not them who voted
for Trump it's us and I also have been
trying very hard to think that my only
the only team I can belong to I have two
choices I could be Penn or I can be one
of seven billion and seven billion is
being conservative I'd actually like to
do a hundred and eight billion for
everybody that's ever lived and I might
want to start adding primates and maybe
other mammals into there but I don't
want to see teams anymore I don't want
to see us in them and I think the
biggest challenge we face even with
climate change on the table one of the
biggest challenges we face is staying
kind with profound disagreement and
staying kind when a mechanism has been
set up to make money and power out of
hate
and I want to believe all the cliches
about love and kindness triumphing and
right now politically that's not the
case they have found a way to weaponize
hate in the social media that we thought
was going to lead to utopia and that's
heartbreaking to me but I still kind of
believe it and I still kind of believe
the mathematics that if you want to
change the world you are better off with
non-violence if you don't even care if
you even put violence on the table
nonviolent revolutions have been more
successful more often than violent ones
and Martin Luther King and Mandela and
Gandhi were not as obama portrayed them
kind of silly WiDi wild-eyed people that
it kind of happened to work for them but
it can't work all the time that might
not be true they might actually be the
scientists among us who had done proper
social change in a way that is not
morally right but is also the most
efficient and my obsession right now is
to try to find a way to to use it insane
phrase weaponize kindness and to be able
to see ourselves as not teams and I mean
teams in every [ __ ] way whether teams
is atheist whether team is Democrat or
their team's is sports fans where their
teams is I love biles Davis and hate
Kenny G where their teams are anything I
know it's impossible but god damn it we
got to work on that and we got bigger
problems coming up yeah agreed that is
an excellent way to close thank you so
much
pen and it was a pleasure - yeah to be
continued I hope we have a chance to eat
a bushel of blueberries together and
continue continue the conversation shops
go fast you ain't getting any
sounds like a plan thanks so much
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs it's a new year 2020 time
for clarity a time when lots of folks
are thinking about personal and
professional growth and in many cases
the growth of their own businesses big
goals necessitating good planning and
good hires if that's you LinkedIn can
help you find the right people who can
set you up for a strong year LinkedIn
jobs screens candidates with the hard
and soft skills you're looking for so
you can hire the right person quickly
how is it that a person is hired every
eight seconds with LinkedIn and why is
it the companies have rated LinkedIn
jobs the number one platform for
delivering quality hires collaboration
creativity adaptability LinkedIn simply
has more and better data they can look
beyond pure work skills and put your job
post in front of qualified candidates
who match your business requirements
perfectly that's how LinkedIn makes sure
that your job post is seen by the people
you want to hire people the skills
qualifications and interests that will
help you and your business grow so find
the right person for your business today
with LinkedIn jobs you can pay what you
want and get the first 50 dollars
just visit linkedin.com slash of tim
again that's linkedin.com slash Tim to
get $50 off of your first job post terms
and conditions apply this episode is
brought to you by brave the next
generation of web browser
I love brave and if you haven't heard
about it here is the skinny brave was
built by team of privacy focused
performance oriented pioneers of the web
and I do mean pioneers brave was
co-founded by Brendan Eich VI CH and
Brian Bondi Brendan was previously the
co-founder of Mozilla Firefox and the
creator of JavaScript brave now has more
than 10 million monthly active users and
I'm one of them why why would I use
break because brave gives you unmatched
speed security and privacy and when I
say unmatched and the difference is hard
to believe and here's why every time you
download a web page when you go to any
web page you are not just downloading
the text and images you are also
downloading web junk this includes
trackers and scripts that run in the
background slowing your downloads and
wasting your time by an average of 5
seconds per page while also draining
your battery faster and costing you
extra in the data charges there is a way
to have the best experience web can
offer and that is by using brave brave
is up to six times faster than other
browsers and it's truly incredible how
much faster everything is I have used
brave for instance to get on airplane
Wi-Fi when other browsers crashed I have
used it to watch youtube videos when
it's just suspended in loading forever
on other browsers it's not a subtle
little there's a huge difference other
browsers act like a vacuum cleaner for
your data so this is on the security
privacy side you were being profiled and
tracked across the web so what you might
ask well data collected about you can be
used to manipulate both your decisions
and countrywide decisions like elections
and if you want more on that listen to
my episode with Tristan Harris brave is
a way to protect yourself and remove the
surveillance economy brave also includes
options which I use quite often such as
private window with tor for those
seeking advanced privacy and safety
this browser feels intuitive it's super
easy to use you can import your
bookmarks with one-click and all your
favorite Chrome extensions are also
available with brave and it doesn't have
to be either/or you can use multiple
browsers for different things
now listeners of this show the Tim fair
show can easily upgrade their browser
for free and all you have to do is go to
brave com forward slash Tim that's brave
comport slash Tim I use brave all the
time and I strongly suggest that you at
least test it out so go to brave com or
slash Tim and give it a shot
[Applause]